france 2
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce dernier jour
de l'année 2008 a déjà commencé dans une
bonne partie du monde de l'australie à
la chine le nouvel an a été fêtée avec
des feux d'artifice géant en france dans
trois minutes tout juste nicolas sarkozy
fera part de ses voeux ce sera à suivre
en direct de l'elysée on annonce un
message plus personnel que politique
cette nouvelle année marque aussi la fin
de la cigarette dans les bars et les
discothèques sans guerre ni drame c'est
apparemment dans un esprit apaisé que la
loi entre en vigueur
150 morts au moins en deux jours le
kenya bascule dans la violence après des
élections contestées les tour-opérateurs
français gèle tous les départs vers
d'aérobie ou mambasa en colombie la
tante n'en finit pas le gouvernement
accuse la guérilla des farc de mentir
sur la libération espérer des trois
otages
enfin des réveillons de 2 à 1000 euros
nous ferons un tour d'horizon des
préparatifs
en bretagne les plus courageux ont
commencé la journée dans une eau à moins
9 degrés une bonne et heureuse année en
france métropolitaine il est trop tôt
pour la souhaitait il paraît que cela
porte malheur
mais en asie et en océanie les douze
coups de minuit ont déjà sonné voici les
premières images de 2008
zine dine boudaoud
un feu d'artifice hors normes dans le
ciel de sydney les australiens ont
tourné la page de 2007 il y à déjà 8
heures parmi les premiers sur la planète
a fêté la nouvelle année
plus d'un million de personnes pour
déguster le spectacle au dessus du
harbour bridge même scénographie ou
presque à tokyo aux douze coups de
minuit les visages et téléphones
portables s'illumine dans les temples
bouddhistes ont pris pour la paix la
santé la prospérité
j'espère que la nouvelle année à fort
sera un monde où la paix s'imposera à la
guerre voilà j'espère garder la santé le
plein d'énergie pour cette nouvelle
année
bienvenue à hong kong un décor de carte
postale où les gratte ciel du quartier
d'affaires font le spectacle en chine
toujours pékin fait 2008 mais veut aussi
montrer que tout est déjà prêt pour ces
jeux olympiques d'été
un mélange de kitsch et de rigueur vive
en france c'est la tradition et elle est
respectée dans moins d'une minute
maintenant nicolas sarkozy fera part de
ses voeux bonsoir alexandre kara vous
êtes sur place
à l'élysée en attendant le président de
la république a convié quelques uns de
ses ministres sur place oui au total une
vingtaine de ministres pour ce pauvre
gouvernementale de fin d'année certains
sont déjà sur leur trente-et-un d'autres
sont venus en tenue de ville
parmi les présents notre à rachida dati
xavier bertrand ou michèle alliot-marie
absents revanche françois fillon qui a
préféré rester dans la sarthe jean louis
borloo christine lagarde excuser ou
hervé morin en déplacement auprès des
troupes françaises au tchad mais comme
on l'a précisé rappeler à l'elysée il
s'agissait d'une invitation et pas d'une
convocation en merci alexandre tout de
suite donc les voeux du président de la
république nous nous restons à l'elysée
en direct de son bureau au premier étage
donc à l'elysée
et
mes chers compatriotes en ce 31 décembre
au terme d'une année si plein pour notre
pays c'est avec reconnaissance pour la
confiance qu m'avez témoignée et
conscient des devoirs qu'elle n'impose
que je m'adresse à vous ce soir j'ai une
pensée pour chacun d'entre vous je pense
à vous qui vous préparer à fêter la
nouvelle année avec votre famille avec
vos amis en oubliant les soucis de la
vie quotidienne
je pense à vous qui êtes obligés de
travailler cette nuit au service des
autres et à vous soldats français à
l'opération loi nouveau foyer et qui
risquer votre vie pour défendre nos
valeurs
je pense aussi à vous qui êtes seul et
pour qui cette soirée sans personne à
qui parler
ce sera une soirée de solitude semblable
à toutes les autres je pense à vous que
la vie a éprouvé et que la tristesse ou
la douleur tiennent à l'écart de la fête
à chacun je veux adresser un message
d'espérance un message de foi dans la
vie et dans l'avenir je voudrais
convaincre même celui qui en doutent
qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité du malheur au
milieu des joies et des peines que
l'existence réserve à chacun d'entre
nous nous pouvons parler fort de tous
bâtir une société où la vie sera plus
facile ou l'avenir pour être regardé
avec davantage de confiance
c'est la tâche que vous m'avez confiées
en m'élisant président de la république
au mois de mai dernier
c'est une tâche immense dans la france a
pris de retard sur la marche du monde
je sais combien est grande
votre attente d'un changement profond
après des années d'efforts et de
sacrifices que la plupart d'entre vous a
le sentiment d'avoir consenti en vain je
sais les craintes que beaucoup d'entre
vous éprouve pour l'avenir de leurs
enfants
je sais elle angoisse qui vous étreint
quand vous avez peur de perdre votre
emploi ou quand vous craignez que
l'augmentation du coût de la vie ne vous
permettent plus même en travaillant dur
de faire vivre décemment
votre famille
je sais aussi votre exaspération quand
vous voulez entreprendre ou quand vous
voulez travailler davantage et quand
vous avez le sentiment que tout est fait
pour vous en empêcher alors bien sûr
tout ne peut être résolu en un jour mais
croyez le bien
ma détermination est sans faille malgré
les obstacles malgré les difficultés
ce que j'ai dit je le ferai je le ferai
tout simplement parce que c'est
l'intérêt de la france
depuis que vous m'avez choisie pour
présider aux destinées de notre pays
j'ai voulu tout mettre en oeuvre pour
tenir la promesse que je vous avais fait
de vous rendre la fierté d'être français
et de vous donner le sentiment que dans
notre vieux pays
tout pourrait devenir possible j'ai avec
françois fillon et tout le gouvernement
engagé depuis huit mois beaucoup de
changements profonds à ceux qui trouvent
que cela n'est pas allé assez vite je
veux dire que j'ai fait tout ce que je
pense est possible de faire en tenant
compte de l'exigence du dialogue social
et de la négociation
je ne crois pas la brutalité comme
méthode de gouvernement
je crois que mon rôle c'est de
convaincre et de rassembler non de
heurter et de diviser c'est ce à quoi je
me suis efforcé dans le respect de tous
à ceux qui pensent que le changement
était trop rapide
je veux dire qu'il ne faut pas perdre de
vue que notre pays a trop attendu et que
le tran presse si nous voulons rester
maître de notre destin
j'ai voulu mettre chacun face à ses
responsabilités
j'ai pris les miennes j'ai pu commettre
des erreurs mais depuis huit mois
je n'ai agi qu'avec le souci de défendre
des intérêts de la france et pas un jour
ne s'est passé où je me sois répété
l'engagement que j'ai pris envers chacun
de vous je ne vous tromperez pas je ne
vous trahirai pas je vous dois la vérité
je vous la dirai toujours je
m'autoriserai aucune hypocrisie j'ai mis
tout mon coeur et toute mon énergie à
être le président de tous les français
et pas seulement de ceux qui ont
toujours partagé mes convictions
c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu l'ouverture
c'est pourquoi je les fait avec des
hommes et des femmes de valeur
je ne leur ai pas demandé de se renier
je leur ai proposé simplement de servir
leur pays ils l'ont accepté je leur en
suis reconnaissant
et c'est avec le même esprit d'ouverture
avec la même volonté de tenir mes
engagements que j'aborde cette nouvelle
année où malgré une conjoncture
internationale freinée par la crise
financière les premiers résultats
l'action entreprise devrait se faire
sentir
beaucoup reste à faire mais j'en suis le
premier conscient pour que les mesures
mises en oeuvre se traduisent par des
améliorations visibles dans votre vie
quotidienne
pour répondre à toutes les attentes que
vous avez exprimées ou pour que la
france retrouve son rang et son rôle
dans le monde
en cette fin d'année 2007 une première
étape s'achève sur la voie du changement
ce fut celle de l'urgence une chance à
dépasser les vieux clivages partisans
une urgence du choc fiscal et social
pour rétablir la confiance et soutenir
l'activité et qui a permis à notre
économie de mieux résister que d'autres
au ralentissement de la conjoncture
une urgence du pouvoir d'achat une
chance de l'autonomie des universités
urgence de réformer les régimes spéciaux
de libérer et de réhabiliter le travail
urgences du service minimum urgence de
la modernisation de l'état qui commence
enfin urgence des réformes qui attendent
depuis vingt ou trente ans urgence que
la france devienne exemplaire en matière
d'environnement de qualité de la vie de
développement durable urgence du traité
simplifié pour débloquer l'europe
l'europe dont je n'ai jamais cessé de
penser qu elle nous était indispensable
une chance que la france se remettent à
parler avec tout le monde pour qu'elle
puisse jouer le rôle qui doit être le
sien au service de la paix et de l
équilibre du monde au service de ceux
qui chauffent des enfants des femmes
martyrisées des persécutés de ceux qui
attendent au fond de leur prison que la
france parlent et agissent pour eux avec
et bien c'est une deuxième étape qui
s'ouvre celle d'une politique qui touche
davantage encore à l'essentiel à notre
façon d'être dans la société dans le
monde à notre put
dur à notre identité et à nos valeurs à
notre rapport aux autres c'est à dire au
fond à tout ce qui fait le suivi
lisation depuis trop longtemps la
politique se réduit à la gestion restant
à l'écart des causes réelles de nos maux
qui sont souvent plus profondes
j'ai la conviction que dans l'époque où
nous sommes nous avons besoin de ce que
j'appelle une politique de civilisation
nous ne résoudront rien si nous ne
bâtissons pas l'école et la ville du
xxième siècle
si nous mettons pas au coeur de la
politique le souci de l'intégration de
la diversité de la justice des droits de
l'homme de l'environnement si nous ne
retrouvons pas le goût de l'aventuré et
du risque le sens de la responsabilité
en même temps que celui du respect et de
la solidarité ou si nous ne reprenons
pas de moraliser le capitalisme
financier
il ne s'agit pas de faire des discours
on en a tant fait il s'agit d'agir pour
obtenir des résultats alors que la
france montre la voie c'est ce que
depuis 12 jours tous les peuples du
monde attend d'elle c'est ce que nous
ferons quand la france présidera à
partir du 1er juillet l'union européenne
c'est ce que nous voulons faire avec
l'union pour la méditerranée qui est un
grand rêve de civilisation c'est ce que
nous voulons faire partout dans le monde
pour redonner de l'espoir à ceux qui
n'en n'ont plus
c'est ce que bien sûr sûrement temps nos
doutes et nos angoisses
nous devons faire d'abord pour la france
elle même notre vieux monde a besoin
d'une nouvelle renaissance et bien que
la france soit l'âme de cette
renaissance
voici mon voeu le plus cher pour cette
année qui vient je souhaite du fond du
coeur qu'elle soit pour la france pour
chacun d'entre vous pour tous ceux qui
vous sont chers
une année de bonheur et de réussite mes
chers compatriotes rives la république
et vive la france
voilà pour cette allocution avec vous
l'avez noté un générique en mouvement et
un message plus centré sur le rapport de
nicolas sarkozy aux français sur le
rythme des réformes que sur les détails
des lois en cours il aura sans doute
l'occasion de revenir sur les sujets
d'actualité lors d'une conférence de
presse prévue le 8 janvier on retiendra
une expression dont on reparlera sans
doute celle d'une politique de
civilisation annoncé pour 2008 et on
reviendra en tout cas sur cette
déclaration dans une dizaine de minutes
avec notamment une première réaction à
gauche celle de julien dray
on entendra aussi ségolène royal qui
présentait ses voeux elle sur internet
autre rituel comme lors de tout
changement d'année et il ya les hausses
et les baisses les nouvelles mesures
aussi qui touchent directement notre vie
quotidienne 2008 mode d'emploi avec
séverine le bras pour passer l'hiver au
chaud
il faudra débourser en moyenne 3 euros
de plus par mois dès devant les tarifs
augmentent de 4% pour les 7 millions de
français qui se chauffent au gaz
mieux vaut éviter les coups de froid car
c'est aussi deux mains qu'entre en
vigueur de nouvelles franchises
médicales 50 centimes par boîte de
médicaments 50 centimes par acte
paramédical comme une séance chez le
kiné 2 euros pour un transport sanitaire
de quoi faire économiser 850 millions
d'euros à la sécu avant d'acheter une
voiture en 2008
mieux vaut vérifier qu'elle ne rejette
pas trop de dioxyde de carbone les plus
polluants donneront lieu en malus le
maximum
2600 euros pour des véhicules comme ce
gros 4 4
les voitures propres donnent-elles déjà
droit à un bonus 700 euros par exemple
pour cette petite voiture de ville
pour faire face aux nouvelles dépenses
de 2008 pourquoi ne pas vendre quelques
rtt c'est désormais possible
celle que vous aurez accumulé jusqu'à ce
soir seront payés 10 % de plus
et encore mieux vincent % pour celles
que vous vendrez d'ici le 30 juin 2008
enfin les bénéficiaires de prestations
sociales devront se contentait
d'augmentation plus modéré plus 1,6 pour
cent pour le rmi plus 1,1 pour cent pour
l'allocation adulte handicapé et les
pensions de retraite dans les trois cas
c'est moins que l'année dernière
l'autre grande nouveauté qui va marquer
ses premières heures de 2008 c'est bien
sûr la loi sur le tabac la cigarette
sera totalement proscrite dans les lieux
publics y compris les bars les
restaurants les discothèques ou les
casinos
jusqu'au dernier moment certains ont
souhaité des aménagements y compris au
sein du gouvernement
écoutez andré santini est la réponse de
roselyne bachelot je souhaiterais qu'on
trouve des solutions surtout là où c'est
le legrand et les mondes convivialité ça
n'a rien à voir avec les avec les villes
mais dont dont les les bourgades les
petits bleds de campagne et bien c'est
vrai que pouvoir fumer c'est encore un
endroit où rendez service je répond
andré qui par ailleurs est un étalon
thani qu'on va le protéger malgré lui
cela s'il veut fumer son cigare
tranquillement à la campagne à dans un
endroit où n'embêtera personnes
n'aura pas d'ego et bien ma foi on
respecte tout à fait sa liberté mais
dans le cadre de ces lieux de
convivialité
s'il fume à cydia il expose d'autres
personnes à la fumée de son cyber vexer
personne ne le souhaite sans doute pas
un chiffre à retenir 68 euros c'est
l'amendé que risqueront désormais les
fumeurs pour les restaurants ou les bars
les ceux qui tiennent ces établissements
ce sera le double cela dit cette loi
semble plutôt bien acceptée reportage
sur ces dernières heures en fumée
laurence de chair fraîche this matter
sur cette table de restaurant trouver
l'intrus le cendrier demain il devra
disparaître ici son destin est déjà tout
tracé à partir de ce soir que les
cendriers montini rosa carton au chaud
pour la can et pour les accros à la
nicotine
à chacun sa solution alors on raccroche
ou pas
il serait une très bonne chose parce que
je voulais m'arrêter magie des gens un
peu arrêté je pense que ça va me
permettre de diminuer très sensiblement
la lose on suivra au soleil dans ce cas
jean faut il y aller non fumeurs ravi ça
enlève les odeurs ça enlève le coup et
ça très très bien et les irréductibles
de la clope plus grognons je ne veux pas
qu'on avait on aurait dû faire des
restaurants du coeur et des restaurants
non fumeurs comme ça que tout le monde
était content pour les restaurants
d'accord mais pour les boîtes de nuit
les lieux de fêtes ou des choses comme
ça mais je ne t'ai vu la loi que
trouveront côté bar tabac les fumeurs
profite avec résignation de la petite
dernière accoudé au comptoir on viendra
pu voir un café si on peut plus fumer sa
cigarette c'est dommage
pourtant le patron leur concocte une
solution de rechange pour installer à
l'extérieur de l'établissement des
parasols chauffants avec des petites
tablettes qui permettront aux
consommateurs de prendre éventuellement
les quelques emporté que si répit pour
les accros de main pas de contravention
ensuite ce sera à 68 euros pour les
récalcitrants alors pas d'autre solution
que dans l'île oui la plupart des
établissements n'ont rien changé à leurs
habitudes d'autres ont pris les devants
en testant des cabines pour les fumeurs
exemple à lyon reportage valérie gage et
jean-marie lequertier c'est une cabine
du skull moins de 4 mètres carrés
glisser entre le bar et la porte
d'entrée
une curiosité qui se visite en groupe
l'usagé du fumoir est encore facultatif
mais depuis trois semaines la plupart
des clients testent ce local
dépressurisé où la fumée est aspiré par
le plafond
ces écrans c'est pratique ça éviterait
aux gens qui n'aiment pas
sortir dehors
c'est l'idéal mais en même temps ça fait
une contrainte quoi ça fait vrai qu'on
est parqué d'autres clients jure qu'il
ne fréquenteront plus les boîtes
refusant d'être placés en quarantaine
ça raconte dans une cabine que ça n'aura
plus aucun intérêt de fumée derrière le
jeune patron de ce bar de nuit lui même
gros fumeur a investi 20 mille euros
dans l'installation de deux cabines la
seconde a été construite sur mesure dans
une pièce du premier étage son but n'est
pas de gagner des clients juste de ne
pas en perdre ma clientèle fumeurs
représente à peu près 80% en accélérant
tel total
si je perds 30% de la clientèle va
falloir que je mette deux personnes au
chômage
tout bêtement parce que j'en aurai plus
l'utilité sylvie muller commercialise
ces fumoirs moderne avec givet
technologies un bureau d'étude situé
près de lyon elle a déjà conçu sur
mesure une dizaine de modèles de 2 à 20
places les normes à respecter sont très
strictes
alors ça suffit la porte au louvre d'une
manière volontaire
elles se referment d'une manière
totalement automatique automatiquement
les créateurs saignante extracteur va
aspirer totalement les fumées et va les
expulser depuis deux mois le marché des
cabines fumeurs explose les
établissements de nuit redoutent les
multiples va et vient des fumeurs
difficile à gérer et préfèrent les
retenir à l'intérieur les cabines
offrent tel un bon compromis
réponse après la saint sylvestre à
l'aube d'une révolution
l'actualité à l'étranger ce soir c'est
d'abord le kenya il ya quelques jours
encore on évoquait l exemplarité la
stabilité de ce pays très prisé des
touristes
eh bien depuis 24 heures il a basculé
dans la violence
les affrontements qui ont marqué la
réélection contestée du président
sortant ont fait au moins 150 morts
claude sans père
la plus grande confusion règne ce soir
au kenya un peu partout la police et les
soldats tentent de reprendre le contrôle
de la situation et s'efforcent de lutter
contre les pillages
mais le climat se détériore de rendre
dans la rue dans les villages et dans
les grandes villes des milliers de
manifestants qui protestent contre le
résultat des élections
hier le président sortant kibaki a prêté
serment après avoir dit il gagné les
élections
son opposant raïla odinga l'accusent de
fraude
en plus derrière ces deux hommes se
trouvent les deux principales ethnies du
pays qui s'opposent les violences ont
déjà fait plus de 150 morts la
communauté française suit la situation
de près c'est vraiment des tirs nourris
pendant pendant pendant une heure très
très proche et et une expérience
ce soir le quai d'orsay déconseille aux
français de se rendre au kenya
les tours opérateurs annulent tous leurs
départs jusqu'au 6 janvier
en colombie la tante n'en finit pas les
hélicoptères sont frais mais la croix
rouge n'a toujours pas obtenu le feu
vert de la guérilla des farc pour aller
récupérer les trois otages dans la forêt
tropicale et le ton monte
le gouvernement colombien accusé les
farc de tromperie et de mensonges
le président uribe lui même est arrivé
sur la base logistique de l'opération
pour une réunion générale il y a
quelques mois l'une de nos équipes
emmenées par dorothée olliéric et
mathias second s'était rendu sur place
en colombie pour enquêter sur cette
guérilla des farc et sur les conditions
de vie au quotidien des otages voici
leurs reportages une jungle grande comme
deux tiers de la france à bord de cet
hélicoptère de l'armée colombienne
on ne voit rien dans la forêt dense rien
ni personne et pourtant sous ces arbres
évolue la guérir
les farc les forces armées
révolutionnaires de colombie ce sont de
jeunes combattants dont beaucoup
aujourd'hui sont enrôlés de force ils
connaissent tous les recoins de cette
jungle et se déplacent avec leur otage
sans arrêt pour échapper aux opérations
militaires
leur quotidien c'est la clandestinité
dans un labyrinthe vert dont ils ne
sortent jamais cette organisation
d'obédience marxiste est néanmoins
parfaitement structurée militairement et
politiquement
dix sept mille combattants dont 40% de
femmes qui se réunissent seulement tous
les deux ou trois ans pour définir la
stratégie globale il retourne ensuite à
leurs petites structures
une cinquantaine de front où chacun est
autonome
ils vivent comme leurs otages avec trois
fois rien toilettes dans la rivière amat
pour dormir dortoir de fortune et
nourriture à base de riz
diana a passé cinq ans dans la guérilla
avant de s'enfuir de se rendre aux
autorités colombiennes
elle dénonce les méthodes des phares qui
brise le mythe révolutionnaire
le combattant de base ne s'intéresse
absolument pas à la politique
on sait juste qu'on reçoit l'ordre de
s'asseoir pour écouter tous les discours
politiques
mais je peux vous dire que la majorité
des guérilleros je pense plutôt à
s'amuser et des balles et lyon avec les
matchs de foot ce sont les moments
préférés des combattants qui les
relations sexuelles sont autorisés la
femme guérira n'a pas le droit d'avoir
d'enfant ou alors ils sont séparés comme
pour clara lauras
direction le pakistan maintenant il n'a
que 19 ans et il est au centre des
regards le fils de benazir buttho
désigné pour lui succéder à la tête du
principal parti d'opposition s'est rendu
aujourd'hui sur la tombe de sa mère il
doit indiquer dans les prochaines heures
s'il va rester sur place ou s'il
retournera à oxford en grande-bretagne
pour poursuivre ses études
bernard lebrun bilawal zardari a changé
de nom en 24 heures cet étudiant de 19
ans a repoussé le nom de son père un peu
plus voir il est désormais bilawal
bhutto zardari première héritier d'une
longue dynastie aussi politique que
tragique
longue vie à benazir crie au pied de la
tombe
le jeune homme au poing levé
inexpérimenté mais déterminée mammadera
et celle de marx
né en septembre 1988 à un mois avant que
sa mère devienne premier ministre
bilawal l'héritier a passé sa vie en
exil avec sa soeur backed avoir entre
dubaï et londres
loin du pakistan mais croisant les
grands amis politiques de sa maman tél
hillary clinton
comme sa mère benazir c'est ici à
l'université d'oxford en grande-bretagne
qu'il fait ses études de sciences
politiques
les poursuivre at il auquel cas ils
abandonneraient à son père les rênes du
parti populaire du pakistan et son père
après dix ans de prison pour corruption
et surnommé là bas monsieur 10% tant
qu'ils aiment l'argent
autre information importante de la
journée au pakistan selon un haut
responsable contacté par la fp les
élections législatives prévues dans huit
jours seront reportés d'au moins un mois
la décision sera officielle demain une
perspective qui provoque la colère en
tout cas des partisans de benazir buttho
sur place philippe rochot tristan le
braz les portraits de benazir buttho
resteront accrochées jusqu'aux élections
comme si elle était toujours candidate
surtout ici à rawalpindi où elle a été
assassiné mais pas de photos du fils
bilawal qui lui succède à la tête du
parti populaire ces femmes qui ont
soutenu benazir pendant toute sa
carrière politique est pris encore pour
elle accepte d'être guidé par son jeune
fils malgré ses 19 ans il est populaire
depuis qu'il est bébé parce que quand le
martyre benazir bhutto a remporté ses
premières élections
elle était la famille bhutto m me là où
elle était la seule sur une chance il y
avait bien la soeur de benazir elle a
refusé car elle n'est pas engagée entre
nous demandons à dieu le parti populaire
de la famille but au sort profondément
touché par cette épreuve mais demandent
pourtant que les élections et bien lieu
à la date prévue du 8 janvier alors que
le parti qui soutient musharraf veut les
repousser derrière ce cordon de police
siège l'homme qui tenait à benazir
buttho dans cette cité de rawalpindi où
elle a été tuée
rachida remède ancien ministre est
plutôt gêné par sa disparition mais pas
bouleverser ce n'est pas moi qu'il les
tuer c'est la violence politique qui est
responsable
bien sûr les gens sont profondément
bouleversé si dieu le veut je gagnerai
la commission électorale qui se réunira
ici demain pourra difficilement imposé
une date aux partis politiques sans
obtenir leur accord car une seule
formation peut à elle seule saboter le
scrutin en refusant tout simplement d'y
participer
en bref encore la zone euro s'agrandit
chypre et malte adoptent à leur tour ce
soir à minuit la monnaie unique
européenne soit un peu plus d'un million
d'habitants à elles deux la zone
comprend maintenant quinze pays et 318
millions d'habitants
retour en france avec une première dans
les centres de rétention les
sans-papiers continuent de protester
contre leurs conditions d'arrestation et
de détention
six centres au total sont concernés
depuis plusieurs jours et à vincennes
près de paris
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenus la
nuit dernière pour la deuxième fois
consécutive
vincent fichman josé vous les sexes
depuis quelques jours le mot classe et
alimenta vent de révolte il ya trois
jours une trentaine de retenus auraient
démarré une grève de la faim
le ministère de l'immigration conteste
l'existence même de ce mouvement
difficile de vérifier ce qui se passe
réellement à l'intérieur
hier soir il aurait refusé de rentrer
dans leur chambre
la police a dû intervenir au téléphone
l'un des retenues emploie les mots les
plus durs
d'après le gouvernement
ces protestations sont à relativiser les
choses ont été remises en état là où il
pouvait y avoir des problèmes
et donc il n'y a aucune raison qu'il y
ait encore des difficultés jeudi dernier
les mêmes images dans un autre centre de
rétention
celui du mesnil amelot près de roissy
nous avions interrogé le meneur abou
indienne or depuis il a été remis en
liberté pour vice de procédure
clandestins depuis cinq ans il
enseignait les mathématiques dans un
centre de soutien scolaire
ces listes a sondé liste de tous les
élèves que j'ai suivi de 2002 à 2007
curieux d'en bas de grâce à moi ça ce
sont mes fiches d'impôt j'ai voulu être
comme tout citoyen white et mme wadel
dont les centres de rétention aucun cas
n'est totalement comparables mais
l'attention elle semble contagieuse
outre vincennes et le mesnil amelot
trois autres centres ont connu des
débordements plus ou moins importants au
revers maintenant comme prévu sur les
voeux de nicolas sarkozy que vous avez
pu suivre en direct et il ya une
douzaine de minutes avant d'entendre
julien dray des images de ségolène royal
qui s'est rendue elle dans une caserne
de pompiers à paris pour mettre l'accent
je cite sur un service public
particulièrement mobilisés pour cette
nuit de la saint sylvestre et l'a
ensuite présenter ses voeux sur internet
en voici un extrait je veux que l'année
2008 soit comme cela a été promis
l'année de lutte contre la vie chère et
je souhaite pour la france est à dire
pour nous tous que les garanties
fondamentales soient renforcés et non
pas fragiliser le temps presse
le potentiel est là et c'est pourquoi je
souhaite que l'année 2008 soit l'année
de la morale des comportements et des
résultats voilà et pour julien dray et
bien ce sera pour une autre fois nous
n'avons pu à l'heure qu'il est
enregistré sa réaction
un accident mortel en montagne à la
plagne en savoie un surfeur d'une
vingtaine d'années originaire de
saint-etienne a heurté un skieur
il est sorti de la piste et il est mort
des suites de ses blessures à l'hôpital
sur place on reparle du coût des
précautions à prendre comme le port du
casque
denis sébastien philippe québec
une piste étroite classée rouge
difficile et beaucoup de monde
voilà pour les circonstances de
l'accident surtout le jeune surfeur âgé
d'une vingtaine d'années aller trop vite
selon les témoignages recueillis par les
secouristes
il est décédé quelques heures après son
transfert à l'hôpital salomé entre les
clients qu'il en a percuté un donc ça
l'a déséquilibré il est monté sur un
talus un peu ce genre là et puis il a
été percuté un arbre qu'il en blanc
renvoyé au mieux nos pistes et pourtant
50 mètres en amont une banderole en
plein milieu de la piste
inciter à ralentir une signalétique
considérablement renforcée dans les
stations ces dernières années mais pas
toujours respectée autre élément
déterminant dans la gravité de
l'accident
l'absence de casque or les moniteurs en
témoigne cette protection est devenu
indispensable
on n'oblige pas à nous les enfants en
avoir mais j'ai vraiment conseillé
c'est très utile désormais rentré dans
les moeurs pour les enfants
le port du casque commence seulement à
percer chez les adultes vos enfants oui
mais vous non on peut dire ça on peut
dire ça même si c'est vrai que on se
répète mais tous avec un casque
comme en vélo et l'on touche toujours
son avance en arrière et je conçois là
c'est mal mais chute en surf donc
systématiquement ray et même avec le
meilleur équipement les secouristes le
rappel en période d'affluence
il faut maîtriser sa vitesse on en vient
cette belle histoire de fin d'année
l'histoire d'un sauvetage près de vesoul
en franche comté une femme n'a pas
hésité à se jeter dans l'eau glacée pour
secourir un grand père et son petit fils
de 6 ans dont la voiture avait dérapé
sur une plaque de verglas pour finir
dans la rivière tout le monde est sain
et sauf sur place stéphanie la fuente
nicolas meyer c'est une route qu'ils
connaissent bien mais samedi après-midi
alors qu'ils se rendaient à une fête de
famille claude et son petit fils louis 6
ans dérape sur une plaque de verglas
leur voiture se retourne dans la
lanterne une rivière dont l'eau est à 2
degrés quelques secondes après
l'accident de voiture s'arrête dans
l'une un couple de militaires dans
l'autre la voisine des victimes l'oma
est rentré dans l'eau en premier je les
suivais il m'a tendu le petit bout de
chou qui était tout bleu que je récuse
même pas reconnu que c'est un ami mon
fils j'ai donné mon manteau que j'avais
enlevé avant de sauter dans l'eau et est
appréciée de dégager le grand père c'est
plus dur parce qu'il est plus lourd
qu'un petit enfant n'a pas à réfléchir
on sait que c'est à nous de le faire et
il faut le faire david
deux des personnes étaient en danger
mais ils ne sont pas juste de bons
samaritains ils connaissent aussi les
gestes qui sauvent d'abord sécuriser les
lieux de l'accident
puis pratiqué les premiers secours pour
réanimer le septuagénaire je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je sauve sa vie alors
je lui ai fait le bouche-à-bouche gelé
frictionner essayer de le déshabiller de
le réchauffer des abymes
le petit garçon est sorti de l'hôpital
de vesoul cet après midi son grand père
y est toujours soigné il souffre d'un
oedème pulmonaire mais ses jours ne sont
plus en danger
on en vient maintenant au réveillon vous
avez sans doute déjà tout prévu vous
êtes peut-être déjà à table
même si c'est le cas voici un moment de
rêve
imaginez que vous vous offrez ce soir un
grand restaurant 1
ou trois étoiles et bien voici le menu à
mougins c'est l'un des plus fins repas
de la côte d'azur
nathalie jour damrémont chapelât sen fou
allegro voir presto ça fouette safri
légumes qui vont accompagner le homard
courgettes artichauts radis et carottes
on cuit séparément dans l'assiette c'est
l'heure des retrouvailles
il ne manque plus que le homard donc la
longue marche des cui une minute à la
vapeur
ensuite décortiquer et rossi dans un bar
de crustacés préparé au préalable son
homard alain lors qu'elle accompagne
d'une sauce au vin rouge pour suivre le
chef étoilé à penser villiers fait
perdre au parti au foie gras et à la
truffe sous le feuilleter un soleil noir
dans cette source la melanosporum reine
des truffes a trinqué au porto pour
accompagner ces mais noble alain orca
voulait des vins d'exception petrus 94
pour le homard château yquem 93 pour le
perdreau s'est donné la possibilité
justement a alors qu'ils entraînent de
pouvoir faire un accord mets vins avec
des vins prestigieux donc qui se paye un
bouteille de petrus week-end donc se
trouver en ensemble avec mon équipe on
pourra retrouver des beaux millésimes
encore qui sont encore accessibles et
qu'on puisse servir éventuellement
ouvert des nectars servis au verre
l'addition n'en reste pas moins la plus
élevée de la saint sylvestre sur la côte
d'azur 700 euros le menu
il est vrai que le dessert est couvert
d'or un réveillon en mouvement
maintenant réveillon sur l'eau cela se
passe à paris sur les bateaux mouches et
nous retrouvons tout de suite en direct
agnès molinier agnès quel est le
programme du voyage alors le voyage n'a
pas commencé vers 21h que la mouche le
bateau sur lequel nous sommes embarqués
va démarrer pour une croisière sur la
seine où les touristes du monde entier
vont pouvoir venir réveillonner je pense
que c'est un des endroits au monde le
plus prisé par les touristes ils seront
200 sur ce bateau 200 sur le bateau à
côté de moi au total six ans embarqué ce
soir pour deux types de croisières une
courte jusqu'à minuit et demi on pourra
quand même avoir fêté le réveillon une
hausse jusqu'à 3 heures du matin les
prix sont un peu
un helvète dans le reportage que l'on
vient de voir 250 euros 350 euros alors
pour vous allécher david une petite idée
du menu brochettes de langoustes foie
gras de canard maison et petit bonbon je
me suis trompé petits bonbons de
langoustes aux crustacés
j'espère que vous savez ont réveillonné
ce soir parce qu'ici c'est plein alors
en attendant on va vous souhaiter une
bonne soirée à tous ceux qui nous
regardent aussi et on va sabrer le
champagne à la fin de 2007 agnès vous
n'avez pas le mal de mer enfin plutôt le
mal de scènes non non pour l'instant
tout va très bien david et bien votre
soirée à l' écoute et bonne année à vous
merci autres il faut pas encore le dire
autres lieux autres menus à lille deux
apprentis cuisiniers encadrait
professionnels réalisent un repas à 2
euros en tout cas moins de 3 euros pour
un centre social d'hébergement les 35
pensionnaires auront le plaisir de
manger malgré tout du saumon fumé du
gibier du carré de biche
le prix très faible de ce repas est
possible grâce aux fournisseurs qui font
cadeau de la nourriture en tout cas
certains pour s'ouvrir l'appétit ont eu
recours à une méthode radicale mais
désormais rituelle le bain glacé
bravo les courageux à dinard l'eau était
tout de même à moins de 9 degrés sur
place jacques devaux michel hiver avant
d'affronter une eau à 8,2 les huit
petites séances d'échauffement
car sur les 575 nageurs présents
les habitués des bains hivernaux ne sont
pas les cheveux que ce soit d'un serra
priant je n'ai pas décidé ranger lui sur
le journal 31 15 heures à dinard donc
j'y suis j'espère planches à pétillant
que comme du champagne pétillante on ne
sait pas mais bien frappé c'est sûr
aussi bon nombre se contente d'une
rapide trempe est vite rentré dans l'eau
certes mais vite sorti housse et puis il
y a les durs à cuire ce qu'ils trouvent
l'autre est bonne ou qui n'osent pas
avouer le contraire allez me considère
très très variable temps et avant tout
le monde n'a pas la même peine un quart
d'heure de baignade pas plus on ne
badine pas avec la sécurité
tout le monde peut se réchauffer la mère
elle a retrouvé sa tranquillité
autre tradition le concert du nouvel an
ce sera à suivre demain bien sûr en
direct de vienne avec l'orchestré
lamoureux philharmonique en direct sur
france 2 aux baguettes un français de 83
ans georges prêtre
ça n'est pas si courant isabelle bechler
georges prêtre n'est plus un jeune homme
mais il en a la fougue quand il est au
pupitre devant un orchestre de la
qualité du philharmonique de vienne
à 83 ans il a eu l'occasion de le
diriger à plusieurs reprises depuis 1962
à bienne il est presque en famille
vous nous comprenons c'est dans des
tailles dans un petit geste dans une
respiration à l'incidence est très
important les silences
mais ça ils le comprennent tout de suite
magnifiquement diriger la musique légère
de la dynastie des strauss- devienne loi
s'il en est il le fait depuis 45 ans
déjà leader un trac fou c'était la
semaine dernière j'ai fumé des vies dans
capriccio et naturellement je crois
qu'ils les viennois enfin a pas mal
marché
et ce grand chef n'a jamais boudé son
plaisir
la musique légère est une fête pour lui
jeudi champagne parce que ça explose et
ilham ou slam ou du champagne qui se
répondent comme ça pour font donner du
bonheur une joie voilà avant de refermer
cette édition douze en appel deux des
principaux titres d'abord nicolas
sarkozy a présenté ses voeux aux
français dans une allocution d'un peu
moins de 10 minutes il a défendu le
rythme des réformes plaidé pour une
politique de civilisation et une
nouvelle renaissance de la france
et puis c'est déjà 2008 dans une grande
partie du monde en asie et en océanie de
pékin a sydney les douze coups de minuit
ont déjà sonné c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de m'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo isabelle martinet
20h50 vous avez rendez vous avec patrick
sébastien et son plus grand cabaret pour
une soirée spéciale réveillon un
réveillon que je vous souhaite
excellent à demain
nous devons
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
site internet
m